Okay, guys, so I want to give you an example of confirmation entries
So on the one hour time from you have this change of protector and we also have this break of structure here. So
Oops, my bad. What's happening man? Okay, so we have change of picture and also we have break of structure, right and
There we have our autoblock
With fair value gap. So this is our POI. Now when price comes back into your POI, you want to drop down to the five minute time for him
And you look for market structure shifts. So did we have a market structure shift here? No, we did not break above this level
So I want to wait for a body closure. Okay, not the week. So
Over here we see price
Okay, so we have another liquidity sweep. So let's assume
Okay, so I believe we have market structure shift. So this is our market structure shift, right and
We have this fair value gap
with OBI
You can see and if I take my entry from this level put my stop right below this level and
We look to target
Um
Maybe this high here these equal highs, right? So
See what happens
So I'm gonna put this at three
And I'm gonna buy right here
Let's just speed this up. Okay, nevermind and I'm gonna sell it here
At around this level
So let me just speed this up actually
And price just keeps on going up
And eventually yep, we hit our take profit so
I'm not sure what happened here. How do I close this out?
All right, I'm just gonna close this here
So you can see that we if we use confirmation entries
It's gonna be really really beneficial, right? So this trade right here was not during the
Killzone, but this was just to show you as an example that how well it can work, okay?
so
Make sure that your entries are always during close-on-ars. It's gonna increase your win rate
I'm not saying that you can
You know not take a trade ever
Like without being in a close-on, but if you take killing kills on into consideration
the chances are higher and
The algorithms are active at that time, but this right here. This was an exception and
This was also just for for an example. I just looked at the chart and I found it. It worked out pretty well
And this is a hindsight as well, but it does actually work
so
You can see that we came into our POI
we had a market structure shift here and
We took our entry from the Fereboli gap and it took its time and took out these level
this was our take profit level that would have been nine nine point three risk to reward and
This was beautiful